Here's an idea that's expressed.
Christian symbolism was an idea that Christ was crucified before he headed to
hell.
The heroin hell and rise to mythological idea.
It's an article and liberal idea as far as I'm aware.
But there's an idea there.
If you want to move out,
you have to go down first,
then you kind of know this,
right?
Because most of the things that you've learned in your life,
you've learned the hard way.
And so most any hole that will increase in wisdom tends to come back,
a sacrificial cost,
right?
You have to die and there's an intermediary period of chaos and horror and then
maybe come out of that.
You're wiser and more work together,
but you paid for it.
And so
one of the things that's being the consequence of that process for me is,
you know,
I've looked into these,
this motivation for atrocity,
and I told you what I concluded you could make about what you want,
but it's all from them.
Something very positive for me,
which was to shed light on something else,
which is,
well let's say you can need,
and this has to do with the solution of the problem.
Let's say you can detail problem and so I need the problem.
If it's,
if it's detailed though property,
then there's a solution that emerges from it.
If you could identify the nature of the true level,
it's then you clarify the nature of its officers,
which is whatever is good and then you didn't perhaps pursue that and perhaps
that's how you can spray the malevolence.
Whatever good is,
is not what he,
and it's the opposite of that.
And some would say,
well what do you do instead of trading trending down half of cane?
And that's answer that is
you don't look for the insufficiency of the world in the structure.
You look for the insufficiency of destruction of the world in you.
If things aren't going well enough for you,
then you have some work to do and you might pay Paul.
That's a hell of a thing because the world,
there's a lot to it.
It's a railing against you in some finding ways.
And there's no doubt that that's the case.
You've got your options.
You can either pass your catastrophe at the feet of God and become bitter and
cruel and resentful and works as a consequence.
Or you can take it upon yourself,
prove what you improve and also assume that the same time that there's enough to
you that you can actually bench.
And it's the same with regards to malevolence itself.
You can look for that upside for yourself and there's evidence for no time of
yourself.
And then you can go after those people that you regard as particularly in the
straight in your world up that way.
But that's how insurance develop.
No,
and there's a better idea,
which is my one love to yourself first and see just how much of that constraint
excite yourself start before you start worrying about how much of that younger,
the constraint it under people.
And so that's why you need to send your house in perfect order before he
criticized the world.
Because all of that,
and then this one seems to go down the pathway that cane go gone,
and the people still go down constantly.
There might making everything worse for them,
for their families,
for the community,
for the world.
You have the alternative of taking all of that onto yourself,
right,
and so that's fine.
In our most profound transformative stories,
let's say the person who revives me,
the world is the person who voluntarily accepts their own vulnerability.
That's what's symbolized by the crucifixion.
That's why that symbol as Gregory Poole for 2000 years,
since the proper pathway is to take on your mortality is your responsibility.
And the second is to,
okay,
seven,
how would I put this
to notice that the temptation that's laid down by the spirit of malevolence is
it temptation that you confront that you have to take responsibility for and
that you have to attain victory over?
It's a psychological drama,
and that's the story that sits at the bottom of her culture with its emphasis on
the dignity of the individual,
isn't the suffering of the individual.
It's divine.
It's not the malevolence of the individual,
it's divine.
It's the capacity of the individual in principle to accept both of those,
to work for the remediation.
And that's the story that allows us our natural rights and our innate dignity
and the responsibility that we have taught ourselves into our families,
into the community.
And it's the acting out of that story that produces individuals who are healthy
and thriving.
Families that work and survive in communities that are integral and don't
degenerate into something resembling health.
And it's important as Carl,
you don't point it out for us to wake up because we're so powerful now.
We need to wake up and you need to understand what it is that we'd be doing
right and wrong for all of this time.
I have to implement that as consciously and clearheaded Layton intentively
properly as I possibly can in our individual lives and to see what great things
might happen as a consequence if you did some
[inaudible].